après les dernières consignes tout le
monde se prépare pour le départ
étirements petites foulées avant de
commencer les kilomètres de la course
au delà de la performance pour les
coureurs c'est avant tout une course où
il faut prendre du plaisir c'est pour me
faire plaisir j'habite dans le coin je
cours donc là c'est l'occasion de courir
mais pas tout seul de faire mon
entraînement à plusieurs c'est quand
même plus sympa
puis on découvre des des nouveaux
chemins c'est toujours intéressant
je prépare le marathon d'amsterdam et
fallait que je m'entraîne avant et
c'était ma dans mon entraînement c'est
ma sortie donc donc de 20 km pour cette
course dans les rues de coignières tout
a été pensé pour procurer aux coureurs
des sensations différentes pendant le
trajet la première course de 10 km c'est
juste sur la route donc un maximum de
bitume pour que ce soit très roulant et
que les cours aillent essaient de faire
leur record sur le 10 km après ces
indices trail donc 150 m 2 dédiés donc
pas trop dur mais c'est dans la forêt de
dassault voilà donc y en a qui peuvent
l'enchaîner ou alors faire les deux
séparément à la fin des dix premiers
kilomètres ces milieux ou daube et et
pierre et jean charbonnel qui sont
arrivés en tête de course avec un
chronomètre de 34 et 37 minutes
respectivement chacun adopté une
stratégie pour avoir le meilleur rythme
pour les courses de la journée
moi j'ai préféré dire à noter dans ma
course comme ça je peux faire la
deuxième c'est noah c'est noah sera un
peu difficile je suis crevé ce plat et
voilà c'est jonathan demme je suis pas
très en forme
normalement j'arrête je vais un peu plus
vite mais je suis bouche que je pouvais
pas aller plus aujourd'hui en tenant une
course conviviale et familiale organisée
pour la première fois par le cap corner
qui prévoit une deuxième édition l'année
prochaine